happy Mother's Day to all the mothers
out there all the mothers and sad
mothers and you know women even they
wanted to be mothers or even men
sometime
you get a little itch in down inside of
your body maybe you've had a strong
casserole or something and you feel it
quake a little and you're like damn is
it is it twins and it maybe is just as
chili powders you know strong chili
powders that was in that recipe but
happy Mother's Day to all the beautiful
women and that humans climb out of to
come out into the world
this Evan Bartels
mother may open minds this is a great
big world waiting right outside mother
Mary's my boy we the people have that
joy
mother Maris my head the why didn't I
try my mother may have slipped away
though I did not damn right oh you can
come for me
that hitter man and you can hear the
rest of that song and it picks up and
it's a beautiful that's a beautiful
piece by Evan bartels the devil God and
me and man yeah I talked about that so I
talked about that line in there every
time
mother may I rest my head though I did
not try my best man in line gets me
right in the damn and then clever Cleese
boy and hits me right in those high ribs
baby them clavicles you know just to
think that mother may I rest my head no
I did not try my best and that for me
man when I hear that it just that
exemplifies really what a mother is to
me I feel like you know it's someone
that no matter what even if you didn't
do your best you're not doing well
you're not you're not where you want to
be you know mother can I still come in
for a hug you know can i still am I
still okay with you and a mother is the
woman that always says yes you know that
you're welcome here you know right here
in my arms and right here in my heart no
matter what happy Mother's Day happy
Mother's Day to everybody man look this
is a I didn't mean it start off kind of
somber like that but life is like that
you know life is like a damn what is
life what is it people out here you know
waving at each other stealing [ __ ] you
know somebody maybe helping somebody or
you know walk across the street help an
old lady across the street and they
steal a little chocolate from her maybe
she had two little chocolate rabbits or
something she was going to visit a grave
site of a die
I bet it and they cop up you know they
cop wanted them hoppers brought one of
them little rabbits and they tuck it in
a jaw you know and they get that sugar
for themselves that's what life is that
turnstyle man it's that lazy susan but
it's nice to know that wherever it's
wherever it spins or stops or speeds up
or whatever
it's nice to know that there's a woman
there for you you know and and so happy
Mother's Day to all the mothers and all
the women you know uh
and all the sons to men it's hard job
Dube out here being a Sun because the
Sun man we will [ __ ] up dude I remember
when I was young man being young boy
mom's coming home you would hear that
dude you would be I'd be knee deep we
would be making mud and the tub we used
to bring soil in from outside rare soil
or just even regular soil and we were
bringing in from outside and get it in
get it in two hours work the soil you
know when we soiled up you know what I'm
saying we ready with the we got the dam
of them you know we got two foot by four
foot of the dam Mississippi Delta
sitting right there in the bathtub and
we cut that water on Brian make our own
just mud and we'd be just making mud
cakes mud pies and my sister she made
like a ding you know a couple layer mud
cake with the with the boot with the
fondant with that fondant icing I'm like
damn what are you doing this is just mud
we're we can't eat this and she were
right happy happy Anniversary Henry in
and I'm like who the [ __ ] is Henry
you're four years old what are you doing
around this neighborhood but we had some
times man but then once you heard one
kid somehow would find out they would
get a thing in their head they would see
the clock or whatever oh [ __ ] it's
almost 5:00 p.m. that's when mom gets
off work and that means it takes mom
nine minutes
unless she stopped have a little
cigarette then it take her 13 minutes to
get home because some time mom pulled
over behind the bank and hit that
freaking you know get that little
Winston in her get that chirp-chirp get
that up or you know that that light up
or that's gonna help her you know come
home and not you know whip the kids ass
immediately she will hear the children
first and and man mom would come home
and we'd be like [ __ ] man we gotta get
rid of this mud cuz now you got before
it was soil but now you added that water
now it's heavy mud the [ __ ] is alluvial
you got a dam you got a a baby palm
popping up over here you got an arborist
beating on the door you know trying to
get a deal and so now we got to throw
all of this mud out the window well we
didn't realize was mom she parks right
out by the window right we weren't
thinking you know logistically we
weren't really there because we were
just children so we're just sitting
there throwing mud out the window brush
sand mud it all kind of just toys in it
it had a bottle of um that suave hair
conditioner remember that [ __ ] with the
pineapple on it dude I'd leave the house
smelling [ __ ] Polynesian I'd have
bees coming over a couple of urban
chicks showing up what are you doing you
know when you had that that suave
conditioner that pineapple fresh and
that [ __ ] would leave you sent it up but
now the mud has everything she throwing
all kind of [ __ ] out you know Daniel
snuck over there he's been over there
doing something you know writing dirty
words in the mud and he got stuck in it
and he [ __ ] went out the window he's
airborne
you know Daniel bro you know he makes
his own choices but they're not good and
so man I remember their mom would come
inside and be or as bro and I don't
blame her
blame her you have you paying 117
dollars a month for rent in a
three-bedroom and these kids [ __ ]
brought about 50 pounds of [ __ ] mud
up into the tub dude because then what
happened after that it went into the
pipes then we couldn't use the toilet
upstairs then everybody had to use the
toilet downstairs and the toilet
downstairs right by the dinner table so
you'd have you know some fancy
Fauntleroy wants to slip off from from
dinner you know mom's grilling up a
couple hot cakes or whatever you know
maybe a couple slices of bacon you know
a couple lean pieces and then some fancy
[ __ ] own he gets a little feel a
little quake in his in his gurney and
his girder in his belly and he wants to
slide off to the side and use the tallit
and dude it was just we [ __ ] ruined
mom's life but dang she kept on with us
she kept on with us man you know mother
may I rest my head though I did not try
my best man I think hits me you know
music is pretty wild isn't it lyrics and
music and things we say like because I
know this guy Evan bar tells you know
he's a man right he's a human man if you
hit him with an ax blood gonna come out
and maybe you know some tendon right
he's regular man but
the recipe in Sodom puts these words
together and he learns a way to present
it and it just and that sounds pretty
beautiful to me and that's Evan bartels
the devil God and me and I had an
opportunity to meet him we all moved
over in Kansas City or Omaha thing and
we almost had him play after a show one
time but we couldn't we couldn't find a
venue but next time we'll do it right
thank you guys for being here with this
this a week this past weekend I'm
cutting this is a little bit of a sad
day for me I'm uh this our last time in
the studio we decided to get a different
studio that has a little bit more room
and
fast it's almost like I haven't really
had a chance to really just be with it
you know just to sit in here and just
kind of feel the vibe man a lot has
happened in here I remember coming out
of the kitchen and thinking man what am
i doing moving into a studio what am i
doing
I don't even know what I'm talking about
and then we got in here and I brought
that Chris Farley picture out of my
apartment the nicest picture out and put
it in here and I was pissed dude every
time because I'd sit at my dinner table
at home and be like damn I wish I had
that Chris Farley you know it really
tied the room together and this is
fighter in the kids old studio and we
came in here man and we didn't give up
you know and I feel pretty proud and I
want to thank you guys for being just
supportive him being on board man that's
what's up you know
yeah it's Mother's Day we got a lot of
calls I'm not gonna I'm not gonna gamble
too much but yeah I feel like I have a
lot on my brain and stuff but I've been
experiencing a lot of stress this year I
know I'll talk about that I know I
complained basically I just complain a
lot and I'm trying to get out of the out
of the complain I'm trying to quit
eating the complain grain and just you
know move on um so today I'm gonna keep
it about you guys and we had some calls
cuz really everything is okay man it's
just my perception I just need to I just
need to look at things differently and
when I get stressed out I need to ask
for help or need to ask why I'm not
really stressed you know and when I
start you know I start getting grumpy I
start thinking people should be doing
stuff any time I think somebody for me
anyway any time I think someone should
do something something's wrong with me
cuz nobody
people are gonna do what they're gonna
do you know and when I start getting
expectations I just I don't like living
that way I don't like being
uncomfortable you know I don't like
being uncomfortable man
and I'm not gonna I'm just not going to
be that way I'm gonna try to find active
ways to solve it dude so I'll update you
I've been off the sugar you know and
I've been off of it and man I'm lean as
a damn you know I'm lean as a dang uh
you know and I'll show that right there
and you can see my arm a little bit of I
don't fess muscle or just kind of like
part him up the way that my arm is but
you know I'm getting real leaned up and
you'll see hungry dogs look over at me
like if I know anything on the street
you know [ __ ] you looking at me format
so I'm starting to look like Santa's
Little Helper when uh when they found
him on The Simpsons remember that
remember that episode when they found
Santa's Little Helper
and he was skinny it looked like he just
been eating uh just air puffs and just
drinking ideal lattes you know just
having nothing just maybe a bowl of just
uh invisible
you know um flake muffins nothing he had
nothing on him and they were racing him
the people down at the track was racing
that dog and making him run and dude
it's hard to run if you don't have a
half a muffin in you if you don't have
half of a real muffin and they made that
damn dog running this [ __ ] I remember
this brought the tears right out of my
eyes
I mean like somebody was collecting salt
water right out in front of me in my
eyes said hey I got a little bit for ya
let's get into a couple calls a man
these are all about Mother's Day and I
appreciate you guys nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three is always
the hotline our patreon on behalf of our
patreon we spent we sent flowers to all
the single moms that we've met over the
past year and a half so we sent flowers
and chocolates to all of them so thank
you and we got a lot of nice texts and
responses and some pictures and man it
really just lifted me up it made me feel
really really good and we put on the
card thank you from the whole tpw family
so just wanted to let you guys know that
not trying to brag or anything just
trying to let you know that you know
that we don't give up on our moms you
know cuz and that's and I don't give up
on my mom you know it's like we don't
give up on our moms you know it's hard I
think it's hard in this world to you
know I think it's harder the life is
hard it is a real battle
it's beautiful battle but don't it it
there you have it but you you know the
thing it'll show you what a baby I'll
every baby come with a sword and a
shield and we don't give up on our
mothers you know and so we don't we
don't do that here
cuz I you know they it's hard
everybody's just trying to survive you
know it let's get into a couple of calls
man
homeward what's up to you my name is
George
thanks for the opportunity to shout out
the most important woman in my life
her name is Sarah she was born in Syria
moved to the states in the late eighties
so you got that Syrian Sarah you got
that imported baby you know you got that
night that fancy bottle it sounds like
you know you got that dane that ends
your mama that [ __ ] you know Aunt Jemima
you knew was good it came inside of a
freaking herb and lady and you know they
serving that sweet sounds more you know
and I sometime you get that log cabin
light you knew that [ __ ] was squeezed
out of a [ __ ] pine tree you know that
different hitter let's hear more then
pop me and my two older sisters out and
she got her job working at a grocery
store she still works at that same store
that's 22 years later man one day I was
looking over some tax information for
her I was looking at a pay stub of hers
and I noticed the reoccurring deduction
I looked it up and saw that it was a
charity that she was donating a fraction
of her paycheck to so for 22 years this
woman who wasn't really making all that
much money in the first place
had donated over three thousand dollars
to an organization that helps feed and
you know educate underprivileged
families I mean I couldn't believe it
but at the same time knowing who she was
it made perfect sense
every good quality I have is because of
her so I just want to thank her and I
want to thank you for the time you bet
man that's very sweet of you
yeah that's a you know that's a
beautiful that's a beautiful message you
know moms do that they keep something
away you know they hold something off on
the side sometimes it's for us sometimes
it for somebody else you know when mom's
a lot of moms you don't realize you know
mom's helped out the other kids in the
neighborhood you know you don't realize
sometimes an extra pat on the back or
putting your hand on a young man's neck
and just telling him he's doing a good
job you don't know he might not be
getting that at home you know and a mom
can do that sometimes it doesn't have to
I mean it's nice when it comes from your
mom but man that even that second hand
you know that second hand affection is
very powerful and I think a lot of moms
they don't even realize what they do you
know even on a group level you know and
thank you for that message man that's a
nice message to hear about to be your
mother
she came here an immigrant and she
stayed and got it done you know and this
hard-working there's something nice to
you see you know the lady you go to you
see her at the grocery store and you
learn a little bit about our life or you
see her at the you know at the place she
works at the market or whatever it is
the bank the you know CEO whatever it is
it's nice to see somebody there
year-over-year you know it's a kudos to
her something give a beautiful lady in
your life let's take another call gang
gang feel my name is Jesse uh just
calling for Mother's Day man want to
share a story about my mom so thank you
for calling Jesse um and happy Mother's
Day to your mom but when I was uh very
younger she actually sent me to rehab
for a whole year hell yeah dude that's a
wise mom and that was really helpful for
me because you know it saved my life
essentially
was addicted to them Dark Arts you know
oh yeah and I feel you did the dark arts
I've been thinking about me recently and
I can feel and sometimes you see you
know you know maybe you'll have a little
bit of soup and you'll hope there's
cocaine in it
that's dark arts you know or you'll hear
a bird or something you look out the
window and hope it's some you know a
little bit some titties or something you
know and that's dark that's when you
know that you know you got a contusion
in your fusion man in the way your brain
that your brain is metal and around your
brains playing Othello with Voldemort
you know your brains out there playing
spades with um with uh who's that man
Professor Snape
oh we're brother but that's just how it
be sometimes man she sent me to rehab
and you know saved my life man so you
know your mother is there to save your
life sometimes I guess Gang Gang hope
you're doing good man thank you I'm
doing good today man and here and that
just makes me think good you know I
talked to my mother this morning and
thank you and that you know it is it is
important your mother sent you there you
know that's why think about what she had
to let go you know and it's funny how
our perception would be like man my mama
sent me to [ __ ] rehab but think about
her
you know taking something that you care
about so much and having to let it go
somewhere like that and just being
afraid and you know that's it's so crazy
I wish we had a button where we could
press it and immediately we could put
ourselves into other person's shoes to
know where they're coming from but yeah
especially when we're young we don't
know it's hard for us to register any of
that man when we growing up and you're
doing all kind of stuff and busting nuts
and everything and you know stealing and
looking in people's windows and [ __ ] at
night you can't you ain't thinking or
not with a level deck so that's
beautiful man that's beautiful tribute
to your mother right there I'm glad that
she sent you and you sound healthy and
well man and that's cool cuz the pills
the drugs that [ __ ] they don't man they
don't care then things dude they don't
have a heart in them right you crack
open and damn 7000 milligram of fentanyl
or whatever dilaudid I ain't you don't
you won't find a vein in that [ __ ]
those things they don't have a heart oh
let's take another call here we go as
always the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three here we go
this is Hannah from Atlanta Georgia
Hannah from Atlanta dang that sound like
somebody out of uh in the thong song you
know Hannah from Atlanta got that song I
love your podcast I just wanted to tell
a quick funny story about my mom she is
the strongest person I know she's
amazing she got divorced and then
actually recently remarried and it's
good to see her happy again because she
hasn't been happy for a long time but in
that powerful in that powerful seeing
your mother happy you know I didn't
realize I mean I talk sometimes you know
I tell the story of my show my mother
won a perm one time on a radio when I
was young and
and it was the first time after that I
saw my mother does there was a moment
where I just saw her have happiness and
I'd never seen her be stressed
unstressed before I'd never seen her be
you know just not concerned or worried
it was just one moment it was just a
look in her eye it was just a moment and
man it just I remember it was did just
had the whole world felt different to me
there's something I have that happens
inside of a chav of a son specifically
and I can't speak for a daughter cuz all
I got inside of me is male male DNA I
mean I might have a little you know I
might get a little [ __ ] around the you
know I got that des booty you know and I
got that urban girl booty but otherwise
I think I'm staying you know masculine
but there's something when you see your
mother get to be at peace that it lets
you be at peace it's like you can't a
child a son I don't I don't know if a
son can be at peace if their mother
isn't at peace I don't know I just don't
know if it can happen I don't know if
it's built into us that if your mother
is stressed or overwhelmed or worried
even if even if it's just all in her
head or whatever that you can't find you
I could never be at peace until this one
moment I saw my mother relax and then I
just I was like oh what is this this is
a new layer that I'm in let's hear more
I just wanted to tell a story about I
think I was about 12 years old she sent
me rollerskating for the first time and
I was extremely scared because I hated
doing stuff like that I was always
afraid to get hurt so we know
rollerskating and I immediately as soon
as I start I fall right on my ass and
she stayed by me backwards with her
middle fingers in the air and her tongue
sticking out at me and she always just
had the best sense of humor and I just I
really admired about her anyway just
wanted to say I love your podcast ending
gang game that's crazy [ __ ] stick boy
your mom hit you with that
Magic Stick right down the middle that's
beautiful that's so funny you know it's
funny when a child when they have a
moment and when a child has a moment
they fall down on something then there's
like a moment there we if your reaction
is a certain way they'll react a
different way I see that sometimes you
know if if you seem overly concerned and
they then they'll keep crying if they if
you like make it funny or it's okay and
then they can kind of make it it's okay
it's like there's these kind of teaching
type of moments and that and that's just
what I noticed I could be wrong on how
many children you know um but yeah when
you're 12 years old that's hilarious
what a funny started what a cool mom
that's such a cool mom man that's cool
yeah my mom always dropped us off she
never really came in with us to do stuff
I don't think but I think also I was at
that age at that point where I just
didn't you don't want your mom around at
some point you know you start to want to
be away from them it's just like birds
man if you look at birds if you watch
march of the Penguins you know human
beings a man and their mother a boy and
their mother just like march of the
Penguins you know the mom goes off to
wherever Seattle or whatever and she'd
get you know trying to get a little bit
of fish and from this guy or this guy
they're trying to you know start our own
little fish her little start her own
little catch or E or whatever you know
just snag him [ __ ] carps or whatever
and she fills up and she comes home and
the baby gets that you know she drops a
little bit of that freaking you know the
saucy exhale right into him and he gets
buffed up and he starts doing weights
and [ __ ] and the mom goes off again and
wherever she goes Vancouver you know
wherever a lot of these birds are at and
some of these birds out there thought
and to be honest but anyway decent
penguin women go to North Pole whatever
you know eating Santa's leftovers Oh up
there and and then they come back and
now they come back and the kids getting
older and he's [ __ ] you know he's
doing cigarettes or he's you know doing
uh you know doing dice or whatever and
I was like well you know she's trying to
vomit into his mouth for say you know
for comfort and he don't want it he want
to do his own [ __ ] he want to go watch
the Iditarod with his buddies or you
know or you know or go thaw a couple
[ __ ] out but then the mother and this
but the mother still loved that boy you
know she don't give up on him even
though he's trying to leave the nest and
it's very similar to humans very similar
to humans overall if you look at like a
chart so but uh but that's a beautiful
mom with that [ __ ] role to be able to
roller skate and flip someone off Jesus
Christ who is your mom Kristi Yamaguchi
sounds hot
thank you for that call a very sweet and
it's nice to know that you love your
mother you know it just it just makes me
feel good oh you know we were taking
some of our patreon questions and
putting them in I'm gonna answer this
one right now this is from Quinn Hassan
and Gang Gang from Down Under and this
man Sam from Australia and I used to
think people said I'm down under I
thought they was a mechanic they was
doing oil changes you know I'm from down
under um but that was you know that's
when I was young and didn't know as much
or I knew just less than I know now
Quinn asked how often are you getting
recognized now that you're blowing up on
a global level
like can you go out and still be left
alone or is there always someone asking
for a photo etc I'm from Melbourne
Australian found it really bizarre
watching you spread organically through
the world literally never even heard of
you five months ago then a couple months
later you're that popular we struggle to
get tickets to your Melbourne show
amazing well I will say there are still
tickets available to the Adelaide show
in Australia and that's in a couple of
weeks I think that's it
um well thanks for the question Quinn I
appreciate it and thanks your patreon
support you know that's how we do all
the you know helping out the single
mothers we're gonna do some other stuff
we have
our game plan on there what's their been
like yeah I have met more people you
know I meet more people but you know
I'll say this the people I meet are
people that I feel like I wouldn't want
to meet anyway I don't feel like I'm
meeting like a bunch of like you know I
feel like there's like like substance
kind of like everybody I meet I end up
heavenly just like a conversation with
if I can I mean that shows it's a little
harder because you know there's just a
lot of people at once and you've just
performed and it's kind of exhausting
and I like to put it all on the stage
you know I like to do what I like to
really you know I'm not just trying to
sell tickets I'm trying to get people to
the show because I want them to see the
show because I worked hard on it you
know and I want them to have a good
experience but yeah it's easier to meet
people but it's easier to meet good
people that's one thing that I've
noticed if I feel like somebody's out of
control or they're you know real [ __ ]
up or something like that I don't engage
in a lot of that type of stuff but
everybody I meet seems you know it seems
to be pretty respectful some things have
gotten a little different like you know
I'll like I got a message from like a
pitcher from the Dodgers the other day
on DM and he just you know he was like
hey man I'm a big fan and I was like
dude you're a frickin pitcher for the
Dodgers dude like don't you have aren't
there batters out there right now I
don't like don't tell have something to
do but so things like that are kind of
interesting and kind of flattering but
then I really get scared about my ego
you know you know I really get scared
about my ego
because I'll start noticing that out you
know like um I started noticing in my
head I get a little bit more demanding
about stuff and I don't like that man I
don't like you know I don't like
I don't
I mean I don't know I don't like that I
don't like that and that's just ego some
of us stress some of its ego someone was
just being tired which is why I'm
excited I'm excited a good offer him go
I'm taking six days and I'm going to
bali bali uh
not the fitness club I'm going to dam
Indonesia so somebody my buddy Simon rec
said it was a good place and so I'm
gonna go I just said [ __ ] it I'm going
found me a place on there travel advisor
and I'm headed to Bali tomorrow morning
so I'm taking a break
but yeah it's interesting popularity is
interesting but you know I I don't want
to be popular I want to be I want to do
something and I don't know what that is
sometimes you know I just pop like
popularity doesn't there's at the end
there's not really a value to it you
know it's it's exciting I'm grateful I
know that like you know me and Dustin
Poirier gonna do a show down in
Louisiana later this year in Lafayette
that's gonna be a fundraiser for his
area you know like stuff like that
really makes me feel good you know just
me like getting to like I don't know
it's interesting I just think that the
ego is very dangerous and so I just I'm
very nervous about you know more people
getting excited I'm excited but I just
you know I'm just trying to be careful
because I don't want to I don't want to
just sit around thinking I'm good and
that seems to be like a side effect of
something that can happen you know I
want to stay in motion and I want to you
know I don't know I just want to be ok
because popularity also seems like a
very dangerous thing so but it with that
said I'm very excited that people are
coming to the shows and the people that
I meet are good people and so I'm
excited to meet them man but thank you
for that question Quinn Hasan and thank
you for being a part of sending all
those flowers to all the single moms
that we we followed up with all and
we'll put some of the texts I mama sent
me some nice text sometime we're still
still coming in
anyhow another question that came in
this is from stefan borg borg borg alec
borg leak more clicky i want to say borg
leak borg leaky borg leaky thank you
Stefan I'm sorry I'm butchering your
name
have you ever grown a big beard or would
you do the big beard look I saw this guy
on a bus one time in Tucson and this
dude had his beard he had a dugout in
one time I saw him and he had a um thing
of cigarettes in there
you know a pack of Paul miles in there
and a lighter and he had it tucked down
into the beard so he could reach in
there and get that you know get his
little sustainability sticks and get
that hit get his nerves level and then I
saw him probably seven months later in
Tucson because I used to ride the bus in
Tucson you know I used to ride the three
I used to ride the seven to get over to
Wilmont Avenue to go I was bus boring
over there and this is when I was bus
going out in Arizona and dude I was on
creating and I was a [ __ ] bus boy dog
I was a bus man David I was bro you know
when you doing creatine to bus boy
you're gonna do good okay I was the only
person at City Grill restaurant out
there in Wilmont and Tanque Verde over
there in Tucson Arizona who was [ __ ]
yoked to get those plates get those cups
yo you didn't finish your bread I don't
give a [ __ ] boy I'll put it in this bus
been half a steak half a cookie a little
bit of ice cream melted in a bowl pour
it in put the bowl in Oh
on to the next table dude I would hit so
many [ __ ] I would hit the next
restaurant brah they had a Ralph and
kaku's down the street I was [ __ ] in
there doing [ __ ] for them freelancing
right our dishwasher was like where DS
from you know when I was a French accent
I don't even come at me I do French how
I want to do French
but dude it was wild man I was a busboy
and now you got these buzz they don't
know I don't know can I get you some
more water and I'm like dude I [ __ ]
brought my own water I pull up a lot of
my [ __ ] cuz I still stay bus woke bruh
damn sorry I should got me heated up
whatever grown a big beer to what I
would it's scary but I think I would
let's take another couple of calls here
for Mother's Day here we go what I feel
this is Jake from San Diego just want to
share a mom talk with you and other past
weekenders back in the day my mom had a
blue arrow star a minivan it looked like
Bart Simpson shoe yeah we had that van
dude but one time my brother and I
thought we could keep the van closed the
door closed if we put a whole bunch of
[ __ ] superglue on it right the little
tubes remember that scary [ __ ] you
finally found out your mom had the real
kind of stuff the stuff that was holding
your parents marriage together that
little tube that hunt you know and we
put as much as that as we could on the
van don't close that bed and it worked
bro it worked for about three months so
where to get in the back of the van and
in the front door my mom was so furious
because she had all her cookies and
newspapers back there for the delivery
route so you know we'd be leaving over
to backseat [ __ ] snag a snickerdoodle
you know snag a [ __ ] sports section
and I'm out there I'm nine years old you
know learning about them Wall Street
Journal's bro
and have you know and getting sugar up
before the day but yeah mom beat our ass
for that boy but we love her man
let's hear more one night it was stolen
but the police found a few weeks later
hello yeah police always found that
astro van thing be burnt out some
graffiti in there you know by the border
this dude took all the back seats out
got caught bringing tea
from Mexico now Marduk's didn't have a
lot of money so she just had me and my
siblings took lawn chairs and folding
chairs back there and she wasn't the
best driver either it was like a rock
tumbler full of kids in there that's
hilarious or no seats in there he said
it was like a rock tumbler full of kids
that's hilarious man dude that's great
man let's hear a little more it was fun
though
it was a lot of fun man safety wasn't as
big of a concern in fact that and you
know yeah safety wasn't as big a concern
because you found out who cared about
you somebody put their arm over you you
know you ride on your brother's at lap
or your your older sister's lap and they
would hold on to you and you felt loved
and then they made the laws you got to
have this piece of cloth they don't have
any feelings at least write something on
the seatbelt that lets you know you're
cared about you know I'd be a I'd be an
arm if I could you know I I do care
about you even though it doesn't feel
like it I want you to stay safe because
well you know you know I got feelings
like put some stuff on the seat but that
at least but other than but numb and
they make the law and you gotta have the
stupid strap now you just sitting there
by yourself you don't know if anybody
cares and you got to live through the
accident you're about to be in with the
you know in the car back in the day dude
you had so yeah you know especially if
you were the little family member a
little Chauncey or whatever you know
little [ __ ] Darnell or little [ __ ]
you know Betty
they had somebody hold you to hold you
down if you've been bad somebody hold
her hand over your mouth for nine miles
while you're going out there to land a
Pines campground and get it you know a
couple grill meats and do the waterslide
man you hey you know you had it and
that's how you knew people cared bro you
got to the dam wherever you were going
and you had a bunch of lips take your
sister's been kissing you a thousand
times you you know you tend to brothers
trying to date a little bitty slippin
you
of notes but he's whole you know he's
been holding on to you with his legs for
40 minutes on during the ride you got
every but you knew you felt cared about
and you were safe he probably got in
nine accidents on the way there but she
didn't need a seatbelt you know you just
needed to be just loved on you know and
that kept everybody safe it was
different times safety wasn't as big of
a concern you know but then different
things happen that Space Shuttle blew up
and that you know really shook everybody
in it but these lawyers man they'll
[ __ ] ruin it all thank you for that
call man let's take another call but
first this past weekend is brought to
you by Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than sorry
create tours it's underlined with more
than 25,000 classes and design business
and more you discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
start a side hustle or gain new
professional skills Skillshare is there
to keep you learning thriving and
reaching those new goals join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get - for our
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now that's
Skillshare comm slash Theo von and it's
a great place to to experience learn if
you want to have a new experience with a
new skill go there listen to something
oh maybe it's hidden something I cared
about you know you want to do claymation
you want to do art you know you want to
learn it you know to work at the Senior
Center and do - um the super positive
putting vitamins in a senior but do it
but watch the videos first learn the
instruction mentals
learn your life man we love you here Oh
let's take another couple calls but I'm
really enjoying this people sharing
stories about their mom dude it must be
fun to be driving that rock tumbler when
you're a mom you know skating by with
that middle finger out sending your son
off to rehab
lots of stuff moms do Co Gang Gang my
it's Andrew from Lafayette Louisiana
called Andrew from that Laffy Taffy boy
over there where it's a soup
everything's a damn soup you step in a
puddle bro and you pull out and you got
a bunch of uh you have you know you got
a recipe inside written on the inside of
your shoe it is good food over there and
Lafayette Oh word along with a story
about my mom you know happy Mother's Day
to all up there
so back in 2008 I was at Bonnaroo
watching Pearl Jam oh hey oh yeah he's
on them on that dust on them drugs
let's hear catching that buzz burners
Gang Gang I've got a little too wasted
and you know I lost my my wallet so the
next morning my mom calls and she's like
oh no you lost your wallet oh you lost
that Sam's card mm she wasn't concerned
about my driver's license or my debit
card and my credit cards she was
concerned about that fans here at Sam's
Club Card anyway it's always been a
funny story we tell just want to share
it with you guys take care I can't get
in conduct gang getting man dude that's
hilarious that's such a mom thing you
lost that because that's how moms think
that thinking man how how is he gonna
get 76 [ __ ] cans of uh of grilled okra
you know how's he gonna get 45 you know
um pieces of squash that are carved in
uh you know statues of Lance Armstrong
where else is he gonna be able to do
that
only at Sam's Club at least have live
animals at the one over and um over in
Vermillion Parish they had live animals
at the Sam's Club so you could get at
[ __ ] carding eggs and then pick up the
mother that made them you know you could
roll right out of there beautiful times
down there thank you for calling a man
nice to hear a call from Louisiana and
dude beautiful place let's take another
call here nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three the last show here
in this studio and uh that's kind of
almost a little bit like leaving a you
know leaving a place it's like leaving a
womb a little bit you know I know these
walls I know this place I know how my
voice sounds in here you know I know my
lifeline Nick Davis though the producer
premature Nick you know he showed up
early and he'd been working hard ever
since bro
and uh and it's kind of like that you
know when you leave to a new place cuz I
don't know what it's gone I'm leaving
I'm out of town for three weeks in and
when I get back we're gonna be rockin
and rollin and it is pretty crazy to go
back to the guys question it's crazy now
to be going to like Australia to do
stand-up shows but I feel like it's not
fake I feel like I'm bringing a product
that is good you know I think will be
scary would be going somewhere and not
being able to do a good show or a show
that I think people are getting to get
their money's worth for so that's what I
hope to do a lot of people been asking
about meet and greets after shows as
well a lot of them the shows don't have
them I'm gonna try to do as many as I
can
after early shows it's harder cuz we got
to do the Late Show
but after late shows I'm just going to
try to do as many just meet as many
people as I can so they usually just
announce it at the end of the show and
thank you guys so much for all the
people supporting and the tickets and
stuff it's crazy man I can't even
you know it's like my dreams are kind of
coming true and we can think about that
a different time I want to hear more
about these mothers man that sounds Club
dude that's [ __ ] wild that rock
tumbler yo CL what's up man it's Mike
from Northern Virginia which most people
know as the less racist part of the
state up here outside DC in the good old
politics though oh yeah they're in Nova
dude yeah let's hear more anyway man
mother's day hasn't always been easy I
lost my mom to cancer 15 years ago when
I was 18 actually the day before I left
for college Wow just want to take a
little moment of silence for her man
let's hear the rest your call as you
know losing a parent young can have a
long-standing affect on you for a lot of
years especially on mother's day I was I
think better and presentable but as I
get older I still miss her the same but
I've tried to change my mindset really
working on that try to think about the
joy and happiness she brought to me said
of just being gone just thinking about
her voice and her smile and her kindness
towards others makes me happy to me she
set the bar for our supposed to treat
others and her constantly working on
imitating that in my own life and you
know bouncy how about amounts of my life
who supported me and I'm thankful for
them as well as appreciate the impact it
had on me Amen man it's a great message
you know uh and you know it's funny your
blueprint that this just my you know my
one-cent your blueprint for recognizing
those other mothers probably wouldn't be
there if your mother hadn't really
created it you know so there
it's just so amazing that your mother
did the work that she did where you're
able to still see that were you able to
recognize it in other people man it's so
powerful dude it's so powerful like
because I think about this I think so
say you know your mother passed and then
years later you know you have an
experience with a woman a mother you
know a motherly moment and you tell her
wow you know hey I just want to let you
know you know my mother passed away when
I was young and you know whatever you
did or said or it just really you know
it hit me in that place where only my
mother could hit me and that's powerful
but powerful for you that powerful that
person because then that person knows
that they then they realize an effect
they can have on somebody by doing
whatever that action was something
joyous you know something loving
something man that's powerful you know
you know I'm amazed really by the power
of connection a lot of times I'm really
amazed by it and maybe I'm late to the
game maybe people been on amazed by it
forever
but I'm a late bloomer you know it took
me a long time to get out of my show in
some ways and I'm still halfway you know
I'm still paying rent on that man Jimmy
um but thank you for calling us sharing
the story about your mother and I'm sure
that she's thinking of you every day man
let's hear more yo Co this is uh
anonymous in witness protection in
Kentucky gang gang dude in this I didn't
know this call was come in and I've
always wanted a call like this to come
in man and this is witness protection
program calling so I'm gonna throw my
hat back on just a just to be a part of
what's going on right now back in the
80s my mom had a technique in her 77
money Carlo when I was a teenager like
14 15 years old I smart off to her on
Mother's Day and she would slam on the
brakes and then backhand me as my face
was flying forward so it really smacked
me in the mouth hard
dang dog your mother sounds like Gary
Payton brought herself that you know she
sounds like [ __ ] pistol pissed off
Maravich dude she's selling she got that
you know that dexterity oh I love her
for that made me a better man gang gang
gang gang man you know it's funny my
mother used to hit me a lot when I was
young she didn't have any choice she was
the only parent she'd have a choice what
you gonna not hit some kid you got four
kids somebody about to get that ass beat
somebody needs to you know especially
when the moms bother itself they got
they got the father's job too and they
can't do it all but you know it's funny
now older I don't remember those things
and some of them I choose not to
remember you know I choose not to
remember my mother as a struggling woman
who couldn't keep it together and who
took some aggression out on her children
because for one it was good for me and
two I don't want to remember my mother
that way you know now sometimes it
creeps in and I do think of her that way
and I hold grudges but in the end it's
my choice and I choose to try and
remember her differently these days I
didn't always
I didn't even when this podcast started
but these days I choose to try and
remember my mother differently you know
I just choose to try and remember her as
a woman that needs love you know and and
that I
because I know at the core my mother no
matter what she had to do spanked us or
whatever I know that at the very core
her she never ever wanted us to see us
struggle and she did whatever her chart
was whatever her path was to try and
navigate that
that's what she did and so I you know
and that's where the choice is mine it's
like I can be upset sometimes and some
of the things and the disconnection and
you know why struggling relationships
now because I don't have a kind of you
know it's hard for me to trust women at
a core level but also then there's
another thing where it's like I can just
choose to not discuss any of that with
my mother I can choose to take that up
with myself I mean some stuff I discuss
with her but I can just choose to look
at her differently and just try to love
her because in the end it helps me get
to a place where I I just feel better
than the end of that road of trying to
just be loving feels better than the
than the end of the other road I'm just
trying to hold that grudge forever and
not and not learn from or learn about it
but thank you for the call man yeah
mom's had some tricks up they sleeve man
and not up their sleeve that frickin
open-handed that backhand maybe you feel
me that backhand man hey Theo this is
Dan from Springfield Missouri man Jane
Jane what's up Dan from Springfield
that's a beautiful area up there
Missouri Missouri that's what a lot of
the older man up there call it Missouri
up there Missouri homework listen uh
talking about mom's my mom went to
college and went to master's degree once
we were all all three of us were in
school and she she's a speech
pathologist a long time
her favorite patient his favorite
balance Coldplay's she went out of her
way to email the tour manager told him
the whole story in the whole business
and worked her magic and the tour
manager paid for free concert tickets
the kid and his girlfriend got to go
backstage meet Chris Martin and the
entire band Wow
does like those like the best on a kid's
life and I mean I was that was some
really cool my mom didn't write about
school so she uh she passed away in 2012
and you know that's no it's rougher
comes out there you know no moms and all
that but
man I really appreciate anything you do
and big fan to show me okay thanks
gang gang man well she's alive right now
man
you know she's alive right now not
that's you know she's alive right now
and that's the kind of woman she was you
know it's interesting how a moment or
two can really define somebody and it's
interesting how we have a lot of time in
our life to really make that moment you
know your mother probably did a lot of
other things but you chose to tell that
moment where she was helping somebody
else not even chew that's pretty
powerful yeah man well she's still alive
right here right now with that story
that's why I love stories man they keep
people alive you know and that's why I
think they've been around since the
beginning of time stories from mouth to
mouth from you know from mouth to ear
because if you do videotape think about
it the waters come baby or whatever the
electricity you know they start Valda
Morton and the Lord starts going at it
sword fighting and the clouds open up or
something goes awry at the Mars factor
and too many skittles for everybody
drown and [ __ ] you know rainbow sugar
pieces all this electronic shits in and
go all we need to have is just the mouth
to hear so thank you for giving us that
let's take let's take a one more call
here we go hey oh happy Mother's Day
it's Alex yeah I play a little story
about when I was in high school one
morning in particular when I was 16
years old I felt this tickling sensation
with my face oh that's an uncle dude
this about mothers and I was a bad joke
thank you for calling out so let's hear
let's hear more and when I opened my
eyes
my mom was gambling was paint g-string
over my face and well I guess my
girlfriend had spent the weekend and she
had left that in the bed and the only
thing she said was Alex you need to
respect a woman's body and I guess I've
been trying my best ever since but
anyway my mom is my hero she emigrated
us to America illegally from
on and she's turning 60 at the end of
the month and it's Mother's Day this
weekend and she never got to get her
graduation rate and when she graduated
from Michigan State so I'm gonna buy her
that graduation with a metadata 495 this
year I love her and thanks for doing the
show big fan
later gang yeah that's awesome man
that's a good story dude you're gonna
get her that piece that jewelry that's
touching man that's it yeah that's
exciting it's exciting to think you know
how to send my mother some flowers but
maybe I can learn more about her and in
the next year and think of something
that could be a little more sentimental
you know get her or something maybe
something she really really has always
wanted you know some of my mother she
doesn't like to tell you some other
things she's always wanted you know she
has like a I don't know she feels like
she doesn't want to burden anybody but
that's that's beautiful man
congratulations and it sounds like
you're very proud of your mom
you know Theo what up this is a grant
from Target Isis what up from Tejas
let's hear it pop up what's going on
great be close to that stray animal
about that man
Louisiana yeah yeah man that stray
animal dude a lot of animals used to
roam boy roam baby mice passing through
like bison in the night homework got a
story about my mom when I was an eighth
grade of TV I got a spanking by my coach
for something that was irrelevant and my
sound sexy out here in Hollywood do you
tell some of these executive males that
yeah boy they'll put you in a damn movie
and at their house let's hear more was
for an eighth grader that feels a little
bit homoerotic yeah that's why any
spankings past the fifth gray is real
questionable so I went home and told my
mom my mom decided to go back up there
and what she told him was if you ever
touch my son again I'm gonna give you an
ass whoopin you will never forget
and that sounds like an Louisiana type
[ __ ] something that your mom might do
well sometimes this [ __ ] leaks over the
border you know because they don't have
a wall down there let's hear more
anyways yeah
Gang Gang Gang man yeah moms will step
up for us and cheer us on sometimes you
know the sometimes they show up you know
what it's easier you know it has been
easier for me to remember times when my
mom didn't show up but you know when I
think about when I really when I take
that edge off of myself and just try and
find gratitude for things my mom did
it's a little bit easier to think of the
time she did you know and a lot of it is
just hearing other people tell their
stories you know we had an astro van you
know my mommy said oh I just remembered
my birthday parties at the roller rink
and then we always had the best cake she
always went across the lake to get the
cake to New Orleans and everybody else
got some local cake and we got this
special this nice cake from over there
she would get it every time because she
knew we liked it you know they don't get
a lot of things or maybe they do and
maybe I'm just speaking from own life
you know maybe sometimes I don't want to
thank my mother or there's something
inside of me that doesn't want to thank
people that doesn't want to you know
that's and that's not the good part of
me I've got to go against that whatever
that thing inside of me says I'm gonna
I'm not going to call I'm not gonna say
this I'm not that is the desk the dark
arts
that's the thing that doesn't want you
to do well or to be well or to feel well
or to make others feel well and you got
a step over that thing
and you got to take control and also I
don't know what I'm talking about so
there's all of that in there we'll get
some more Petri on questions next week
do some great calls and thank you so
much nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three as always as the hotline
there are new shows going on sale this
week some extra shows in a couple of
cities and I think those cities are
Atlanta got a new show going on let me
see
yeah Atlanta oh wait Austin Oklahoma
City Sacramento and Atlanta I think all
those places have some new shows going
on as well tickets are available now for
Glasgow Dublin ozlowe Stockholm London
Manchester and Amsterdam that's crazy I
can't even believe that we have to do
all these shows but [ __ ] you that's
going on stage in Australia in a couple
weeks
there won't be an episode next week I'm
taking a break so there will be guest
episodes on the Thursdays but there
won't be one next weekend I'm just
taking a break and and this is a great
place to take a break and and I'm gonna
miss the studio man I'm gonna miss it
you know and I'm scared I don't know
what's gonna happen at the news to you
we got more room we got more but
there'll be more room I think just for
you know when little Gianni comes in
help with the booking we got you know a
lovely finance lady we might get her you
know get her a desk or something do
something like that get her a little art
you know we're gonna try to you know
we're gonna try to work on a cartoon
full time with Pappy Oh
but just thank you so much for every for
everything man you guys have you know
this has been a blast it's been a real
blast and and we're gonna do a lot of
good with that with the momentum that
we've created and I hope that you hold
us to that because we're gonna hold
ourselves to that as well we'll finish
out this Mother's Day episode with the
second half of that Evan bartels the
devil God and me the link to his song
will be on on the YouTube thank
everybody thank you for the patreon and
support yeah and and even though you
called your mom yesterday you call her
again if you want you know and dad's too
you know know when we'll get into dads
and we'll do a special section thing for
them sometime and next week I don't know
what we'll talk about we're not does
about anything
you guys be good to yourselves man you
deserve it and thank you so much for the
wonderful calls okay
oh I do have your may stuck in my ear
and down the plain though I beg you let
me be there will you know my plea the
crown of legs I wear insane
that would give draggy death you can
call me
day
but you can come with me
we give a sign are from the studio Nick
Jesus though I had my face
and will you cast man doubts away
take my sins down debris
if there is holes and let me see
there is laughs those like me
you can come for me
Oh Lord you can't comfort me
ha you can come with me
he'll conquer thee
you